so suddenly the same kind of nihilism
you're seeing in our foreign policy we
don't care what happens you're seeing
applied to our domestic policy and even
to questions of science so the people in
charge are telling you that biological
sex isn't real and if you disagree
you're a racist now for a lot of
lifelong democrats this is bewildering
they didn't sign up for this
colin wright's been a democrat all his
life didn't sign up for this so a year
ago he came up with a cartoon to
illustrate what he thought was going on
he hasn't changed but the people who
represent him in the democratic party
have become very unreasonable elon musk
agrees he just shared this cartoon on
twitter in wall street journal op-ed
colin wright explained that he made the
cartoon to
kind of sort out how he feels as a
lifelong democrat colin wright is an
evolutionary biologist and we're happy
to have him join us tonight colin thanks
so much for coming on so you can
describe this better than i can
paraphrase what why did you draw this
cartoon what does it mean
yeah so i drew this cartoon in bed one
night in my pajamas
because i had this increasing feeling of
alienation from uh you know the
political left on a lot of core values
that i felt were you know central to who
i was as a as a voter so on issues such
as free speech for instance that i think
the left had held as being sacrosanct
for
much of its history um you know it's
it's been um
these values of free speech were
generally held to be like these these
core values in order to uphold
free speech to speak truth to power
and it's being increasingly viewed as
sort of um
well it's unacceptable i mean people are
being called racist for wanting free
speech and you keep hearing that
is that when you signed up as a liberal
or democrat or you thought the
democratic party represented you even
five years ago would it would it have
been plausible that somebody in msnbc
would say you're racist if you want free
speech
well no see it's being increasingly
viewed as hostile to
to the government um as being a hostile
to you know these ideas that we have of
of of free speech
and on issues such as like racism for
instance where the previous values that
we had of judging people by the content
of their character for instance rather
than by
you know the color of their skin this
has been replaced by these sort of
identity politics and equity initiatives
that are really valuing group
group identity over individual rights
and then on the issues of women's rights
for instance
we see you know and i don't think the
the right has been always the best or
most consistent on these issues
but at least the right knows what a
woman is you know as an adult human
female
and i say this as a biologist so i see
that with certainty um the left on the
other hand you know they can't even tell
you what a woman is so they can't even
really pretend to understand uh or to
protect women's rights um so this is
kind of my growing feeling of of being
disaffected from the left on these many
issues i think a lot of americans and
people abroad feel the same way i think
that people abroad too i agree with that
it's not just in this country the world
takes its cues from us
the west does and they're they're
shocked by colin wright thank you for
that if if you like that conversation we
had a long conversation with colin
wright for an episode of tucker carlson
today you can check it out on fox nation
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight